ecuador enfrenta múltiples desafíos bajo
la presidencia de guillermo lasso el
país uno de los más afectados en américa
al inicio de la pandemia se encuentra
sumido en una crisis tanto sanitaria
como económica para el nuevo mandatario
la vacunación es clave y por eso se
trazó el ambicioso objetivo de inmunizar
a 9 millones de personas en sus primeros
100 días necesitamos que los
ecuatorianos salgan de sus casas
recuperen la normalidad vivan con
tranquilidad vayan a sus empleos puedan
emprender y también puedan en las noches
ir a los lugares de diversión de
esparcimiento y de esa forma de
reactivar la economía en 2020 la
economía ecuatoriana se contrajo un 7 8
% la caída más profunda en décadas el
país cuenta con una deuda nacional de
unos 70 mil millones de dólares un
tercio de la población vive en la
pobreza y aunque el desempleo formal es
del 7% gran parte de la población se
encuentra en condiciones de subempleo o
trabajo precario
además se cuenta con acceso limitado al
financiamiento externo luego de recibir
7500 millones de dólares por esa vía en
2020 y ahora espera de renegociar los
2.500 millones que restan del préstamo
del fondo monetario internacional
en este complejo escenario y para
disminuir el déficit fiscal plazo ha
propuesto reducir el gasto público
elevar la producción petrolera dar
incentivos a la inversión extranjera
combatir la corrupción y crear al menos
un millón de empleos propuestas
ambiciosas que pueden chocar con su
escaso apoyo en la asamblea nacional con
solo 12 de 137 escaños el nuevo gobierno
deberá negociar para sacar adelante sus
proyectos un escenario que ya encontró
su primer traspié luego de rechazar un
acuerdo tripartito con el partido
socialcristiano aliado en las elecciones
y la principal fuerza opositora la
alianza un es que agrupa el correísmo
nunca prepare que se use a esos
ecuatorianos y sus últimos anhelos como
moneda de cambio en un trueque de voto
con mayoría de mujeres al frente de las
áreas sociales de sus gabinetes lazos
prometió también una lucha sin tregua
contra la violencia de género enfrentar
la delincuencia organizada y la crisis
carcelaria y respetar la independencia
judicial han sido otras de las metas
trazadas por el mandatario conservador